تلوح في السماء في شمال
إسرائيل عشرات الصواريخ التي تم إطلاقها من
لبنان يوم الخميس وفقًا
لقوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية التي قالت إنها
اعترضت معظمها لكن بعضها
أثر على هذه السيارة التي أصابت بلدة فسوطة الإسرائيلية
وفي شلومي كانت واجهة متجر
هذا البنك  لقد دمرت ولم
أقرر أبدًا أن رحمتي التي كنت في منزلي
كانت مخيفة للغاية وما زلت
أرتجف لأنها قالت إنه
ليس من المفترض أن يرى الأطفال هذا في
هذا العصر ، ويقول الجيش اللبناني إنه وجد
قاذفات الصواريخ والصواريخ بالقرب
منها  الحدود الإسرائيلية يوم الخميس
وتعمل على تفكيكها ،
وجهت إسرائيل أصابع الاتهام إلى
الفصائل الفلسطينية ولا تعتقد أن حزب
الله اللبناني هو المسؤول الذي
قال الجيش الإسرائيلي إنه سينقله
ليقرر مكان وزمان رده
ليس منذ الحرب.  بين لبنان وإسرائيل
في عام 2006 ، تم إطلاق الكثير من الصواريخ
عبر الحدود في إشارة محاربة
للتصعيد في وقت متوتر بالفعل
للمنطقة
اقتحمت الشرطة الإسرائيلية مسجد أليكسا
عدة مرات هذا الأسبوع حيث
تجمع فلسطينيون لمشاهدة
لقطات رمضانية من داخل المسجد أظهرت
الإسرائيليين.  الشرطة تضرب بعض المصلين
بالهراوات وأعقاب البنادق وتقول الشرطة
إنها تحركت بعد أن
تحصن فلسطينيون داخل المسجد
من خلال الحجارة وأشعلوا الألعاب النارية.  من
الواضح أن الاثنين مترابطان ، نحن
للأسف في هذه اللحظة بالتحديد
لحظة خطيرة عملنا لعدة
أشهر لتجنبها وهي اللحظة التي
اندلع فيها العنف حيث انتهى اليوم الأول من عطلة
عيد الفصح
رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو  دعا إلى اجتماع لمجلس
وزرائه الأمني ​​، حيث
اشتعلت النقاط الساخنة المتعددة في وقت واحد في
الوقت الذي يبدأ فيه عيد الفصح في هذه الأرض المقدسة ،
ومن المفترض أن تحتفل الديانات الرئيسية الثلاث.